[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de medio ambiente
de france 24 yo soy maría clara calle y
hoy estamos en mosquera un municipio a
las afueras de bogotá la capital
colombiana que fue noticia porque hace
algunos días la espuma del río boyacá
que ustedes ven detrás de mí alcanzaba
hasta los cinco metros de altura esto
estaba perjudicando a los habitantes del
sector los puentes aquí en el municipio
de mosquera desde france24 vinimos hasta
acá y conversamos con ellos quienes nos
contaron las historias que decían que
esta contaminación no solo es de esta
semana sino que años anteriores ya se
había producido esta es la historia de
ellos
una nube de espuma de más de 5 metros de
alto es el resultado de la contaminación
del río boyacá los habitantes de
mosquera en cundinamarca colombia no
saben todavía si es tóxica pero cargan
con las consecuencias y es que la espuma
se desbordó hasta cubrir las paredes de
las casas yo me creo la más perjudicada
de eso porque el todo se viene para acá
y me cubre eso las paredes las ventanas
es una agua engrasada engrasada y huele
a inmundo
eso le cae a uno en la piel y eso le le
pica a uno todo eso flor vive hace más
de 40 años en los puentes el sector
afectado en mosquera dice que la espuma
engrasa su casa y que el olor del río es
fétido hay veces eso es que no pueden ni
dormir del mismo olor que le entra y
como el olor quien lo que en la etapa si
por las rendijas y todo se entra a
finales de abril las autoridades
hicieron tres rondas de exámenes
clínicos para estudiar si la
contaminación afectaba la salud de los
habitantes la respuesta oficial es que
nadie se enfermo pero luz mariela la
presidenta de la junta de acción comunal
cree que los efectos se verán después 6
un seguimiento no encontramos a nadie
enfermo por el momento pueda que no pero
no sabemos más adelante esto que pueda
traer que pueda transmitir pues está
contaminación que tenemos hoy en día
mariela denuncia que la espuma y la
contaminación no son nuevas de hecho nos
compartió imágenes de la misma situación
pero en 2016 ella sostiene que las
autoridades sólo escucharon sus quejas
esta vez después de que los medios
nacionales e internacionales reportaron
la contingencia aunque los organismos
ambientales enfatizan en que el uso
desmedido de detergentes por parte de
los habitantes es gran parte del
problema mariela sostiene que la culpa
es de las aguas negras que llegan de
otros municipios como madrid y
facatativá a cabían peces la gente en
momentos de su vivienda se se pesca y se
podía consumir eso ya dejó de existir ya
cuando empezaron a votarnos todas las
aguas negras esto está como desde el
2000 que metieron una tubería para por
detrás del sector de la falta de una
tubería grande ella le pide a las
autoridades que protejan la salud de las
cerca de 1500 personas que viven en el
sector de los puentes y cree que la
manera de hacerlo es atender los
llamados contra la contaminación del río
las aguas contaminadas de este río en el
municipio de mosquera terminan en el río
bogotá que es el principal de la capital
colombiana veamos cómo es la composición
de estas zonas hídricas de este lugar
del país el río boyacá atraviesa los
municipios de facatativá madrid y
mosquera luego desemboca en el río
balsillas que a su vez termina en el río
bogotá llevando así las aguas
contaminadas al principal afluente de la
capital colombiana y que atraviesa otros
46 municipios
y en france 24 también hablamos con las
autoridades ambientales para entender
que están haciendo frente a esta
problemática ellos nos explicaron que
tanto en la parte baja de la cuenca como
en la alta están planeando un dragado
inicialmente para quitar los buchones
que le quitan el oxígeno a estas cuencas
y luego para remover bastantes millones
cúbicos del lodo escuchamos lo que nos
dijeron
que generó la espuma del río en mosquera
la corporación autónoma regional de
cundinamarca la encargada de la
vigilancia ambiental explica que están
haciendo monitoreos sobre las aguas que
lanzan todas las industrias a los ríos
de la zona los resultados todavía no se
conocen pero dicen que la espuma no es
tóxica entonces la totalidad de
resultados los informaremos a la
comunidad pero hasta el momento no se
encuentra alguna sustancia tóxica que
pueda
tóxico y siempre hemos hecho la
recomendación a la comunidad que no
toque la espuma los habitantes del
sector de los puentes de mosquera
denuncian que las autoridades no
remueven los buchones que son las
plantas que crecen sobre el agua y que
le quitan oxigenación sin embargo la
corporación se defiende diciendo que si
estaban removiendo los colchones sólo
que no alcanzaron a llegar al sitio la
corporación ya venía previendo esto y ya
venía dando unas obras de adecuación y
de limpieza desde la desembocadura aguas
arriba y pues no alcanzamos a llegar al
punto porque pues la anterior de
invierno se intensificó y eso nos generó
vamos a llegar a la alcaldía de mosquera
acepta que antes sí hubo espuma pero que
nunca había sido tanta pues la lluvia
empeoró a la situación los registros
meteorológicos indicaron que básicamente
llovió digamos que cayó una lámina de
agua tres veces más de lo normal de lo
que pudiera ser uy llegado en esta época
de alta precipitación que de alguna otra
manera pues es predecible dentro de los
fenómenos de la niña digamos que alta
precipitación en el país pero pues esta
vez digamos que yo veo considerablemente
y pues hizo digamos que la condición
particular de tener aquí este resalto
hidráulico pues hace que que como tal
haya un golpe hidráulico del agua a
diferencia de lo que dice la comunidad
la alcaldía explica que las aguas
residuales del municipio se tratan en
una planta y terminan en el río
subachoque mientras que la cara asegura
que está estudiando todos los
vertimientos para entender de dónde
viene la contaminación
hasta aquí la crónica de medio ambiente
desde el municipio colombiano de
mosquera ustedes sigan conectados con
france24 y consulten más información
ambiental en france 24 punto com nos
vemos la próxima semana